[Musique]
bonjour et à quelqu'un
servez jackson et là on a des questions
à poser
montrez-moi hommage un spécial francis
monsieur cuissardes
je suis venu enquêter sur la disparition
de votre femme et de votre enfant c'est
bien la voiture de votre femme monsieur
pritchard et ne fait rien que tu
regretterait non les masses sur la tête
wissant brickyard pas ici c'était quoi
ça je vais fouiller la misère je ferais
pas ça cgt goût dieu m'est témoin que je
ne serai pas responsable de ce qui va se
passer
jean-francis j'ai du mal à vous entendre
vous me recevait à vous
qu'est ce que c'était dis lui d'arrêter
dit lui de revenir maintenant qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans ce sous-sol à dans la
casse quelles que soient vos croyances
site un dément ce n'est déjà fait il ya
très peu de réseaux dans le coin
c'est terminé le dossier clos
sans moi de la colt
[Musique]
vous
identifiez vous